[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild hallo zusammen und herzlich
willkommen zurück bei Tatort
Deutschland Stefan als die Welt im Jahr
2020 völlig auf dem Kopf stand als wir
alle zu Hause festsaßen hoffnungsvoll
auf die Impfung warteten und W wie
Inzidenz mRNA und Aerosole
Hauptbestandteil unserer Wortschätze
waren was hast du da gemacht um dich
abzulenken t das waren komische Zeiten
also wahrscheinlich habe ich wie fast
alle jede Menge Zeit auf der Couch
verbracht und alle möglichen
Streamingdienste irgendwie strapaziert
ich war tatsächlich auch ab und zu
angeln das kann man sehr gut machen auch
im Lockdown also an der frischen Luft
und zeitweise gab es tatsächlich nicht
so viel zu tun das kann ich sehr gut
nachvollziehen wir alle waren auf der
Suche nach Ablenkung nach neuen
Abenteuern um uns den
coronaalltag irgendwie schöner zu
gestalten und auf eine schicksalhafte
Weise darauf ven wir nämlich hinaus der
Mirko und ich beginnt unser heutiger
Fall genau da der Einschnitt in unser
allerleben und unsere Pläne durch die
Pandemie und die daraus resultierenden
Entscheidungen die im Fall von Scarlet
Salice alles
verändern im September 2
verschwindet die 26jährige erfahrene
Wanderin spurlos im Schwarzwald und wenn
wir hier von spurlos sprechen dann
meinen wir das genauso wortwörtlich
scarlett ist seit dem 10 September 2020
wie vom Erdboden verschluckt und seitdem
sucht ihre Familie unnachgiebig nach
ihrer Tochter und Schwester ich bin
Stefan Netzeband und schön dass ihr
heute wieder dabei seid und ich bin
Mirko Kasimir hallo
zusammen Scarlet ist eine eine
lebensfrohe junge Frau und lebt in Bad
lipspringe in nordrheinwestfall seit
ihrer Kindheit verbringt die
26-Jährige viel Zeit in der Natur daraus
entsteht unter anderem ihre Liebe fürs
Reisen fremde Kulturen zu erkunden und
dann auch zu
erforschen im November 2019 zieht es
Scarlet nach Myanmar dort lernt sie
ihren späteren Freund Joey kennen vier
Monate reist das frisch verliebte Paar
gemeinsam durch Südostasien die beiden
haben Gre plne Scarlet will Joey
heiraten mit ihm nach China ziehen und
dort als Englischlehrerin arbeiten aber
im März 2020 muss das Paar seine Reise
und seine Pläne vorerst
unterbrechen hier ist das erste deutsche
Fernsehen mit der
[Musik]
Tagesschau heute im Studio Judit rers
guten Abend meine Damen und Herren ich
begrüße sie zur Tagesschau erstmals ist
ein deutscher Staatsbürger am neuartigen
Coronavirus gestorben covid-19 can beed
as a pandemic we will suspend all TRAV
Europe even es geht darum das Virus auf
seinem Weg durch Deutschland zu
verlangsamen diese Situation ist ernst
und sie ist
offen die Pandemie legt Verkehre überall
auf der Welt lahm Scarlett muss zurück
nach Deutschland das Paar verabschiedet
sich wie sie damals annehmen nur
vorübergehend ihre Trennung soll ja nur
von kurzer Dauer sein zurück in Europa
geht Scarlet gemeinsam mit ihrer Mutter
den Jakobsweg auf Ihrer Route lernen Sie
weitere Pilger kennen die der
26-Jährigen vom Schluchtensteig erzählen
eine knapp 120 km lange Wanderroute im
Schwarzwald herausfordernd tiefgründig
und aussichtsreich und als einer der der
besten Wanderwege Deutschlands wird der
Schluchtensteig auf einer Website
beschrieben die Route ist in sechs
Etappen unterteilt diese sind jeweils
etwa 20 km lang die letzte Etappe ist
zwischen den Orten totmos und weer und
etwa 23 km lang erfahrene Wanderer
brauchen dafür etwa 7inhalb Stunden
beschrieben wird die Strecke unter
anderem so bis zu 200 m hoch bauen sich
die felsigen bahnwaldhänge über dem in
der Tiefe schäumenden Fluss auf ein
schmaler fah führt am hirschfelsen und
pfeiferskopf vorbei tief unten sieht man
die aus den Felsen gehauene Straße in
der
Schlucht klingt schön aber auch
gefährlich und genau auf dieser Etape
verschwindet Scarlet spurlos bis heute
was ist passiert ist sie gefallen oder
wurde sie etwa Opfer eines Verbrechens
aber der Reihe
nach scarlett ist begeistert von der
Idee des des schluchtensteigs Anfang
September setzt sie sich in ihren
schwarzen Peugeot und fährt in den
Schwarzwald eine Woche will sie dort
alleine wandern im Anschluss PL Scarlet
noch eine Freundin in Mainz zu besuchen
und so beginnt die erfahrene Wanderin
ihre Route im
Schluchtensteig die ersten Etappen
laufen reibungslos tagsüber wandert die
26-Jährige abends sucht sich Scarlet
entweder ein billiges Hotel oder einen
schönen Platz im Wald um dort zu
übernachten bevor es am nächsten morgen
weitergeht ihrer Familie und ihren
Freunden schickt Scarlet viele
Nachrichten und Fotos ihrer Reise sie
wirkt glücklich und
zufrieden am Morgen des 10 September
2020 bricht Scarlet auf diese letzte
Etappe auf von tottmoos durchs weratal
bis zur Zielstation des schluchtensteigs
die Stadt weer die letzte Nacht vor
ihrem Verschwinden verbrachte Scarlet s
hier in der kirchberghütte bei todmos
für gerade mal 28 € hatte sie hier ein
recht günstiges Nachtquartier gefunden
gegen 9:30 Uhr ging sie hinüber ins
Hotel Rössle beglich die Rechnung wobei
eine Überwachungskamera sie dabei
einfing wie sie mit dem Hotelchef noch
ein paar Worte wechselte danach ging sie
mit ihrem markanten roten Rucksack über
den Parkplatz Richtung Todd Moos wo sie
gegen 10:04 Uhr am edik Markt eintraf 11
Minuten bis 10:15 Uhr verbrachte Scarlet
an jedem septembermgen hier im
schmitzmarkt in totmos das ergab später
die aus
Handys sie kaufte sich ein Smoothie und
etwas beim bcker die Aufnahmen der
Überwachungskamera sind die letzten
Bilder von Scarlet mit denen die Polizei
in Wald zutingen nach der jungenfrau
fandet das ist Bildreporter Jörg
völkerling ihr kennt ihn vielleicht
schon aus anderen Tatort Deutschland
folgen wie die Mordfall Luise im Sommer
2021 hat er sich auf die Spuren von
Scarlet begeben und Vorort im
Schwarzwald
recherchiert nach Ihrem Einkauf ruft
ihren Freund Joey in China an es ist das
letzte Mal dass sich ihr Handy in einen
Mobilfunkmast einloggen wird danach
beginnt die erfahrene Wanderin die
sechste Etappe des schluchtensteigs die
Etappe die alles verändern
wird es ist Freitagabend der 11
September Scarletts Freundin wartet seit
Stunden in Mains auf die
26-Jährige versucht sie immer wieder zu
erreichenge versuchen Sie es später noch
einmal am nächsten Morgen zwei Tage sind
jetzt vergangen seitdem scaret zu ihrer
letzten etapppe aufgebrochen ist melden
scarlets Eltern ihre Tochter als
vermisst die Vermutung liegt nahe dass
Scarlet abgestürzt sein könnte
vielleicht hilflos ist aber noch am
Leben sein könnte Tracking Guide Björn
kunik selbst in der Nähe des
schluchtensteigs aufgewachsen gibt Jörg
völkerling im Sommer
2021 seine Einschätzung über diese
sechste und letzte Etappe gerade in der
größeren Schlucht die weiter unten kommt
Richtung Bär teilweise gar kein
Handyempfang die ist wirklich richtig
steil und mit sehr ausgesetzten Stellen
da ja hat man schlechte Karten wenn man
da
runterrutscht es beginnen also
umfassende Suchmaßnahmen um die junge
Wanderin zu finden Feuerwehrmänner
Bergretter das Technische Hilfswerk und
Wärmebildkameras sind im Einsatz sogar
eine Hundestaffel mit 35 Hunden sucht
nach Scarlet am Himmel fliegen
Polizeihubschrauber und Drohnen um links
und rechts vom Schluchtensteig das
Gelände abzusuchen leider
erfolglos Tage später wendet sich sogar
ein Hellseher an die Ermittler sagt er
wüsste wo Scarlet abgestürzt sei doch
auch am angegebenen Ort finden die
Einsatzkräfte die vermisste Wanderer
nicht nach zwei Wochen suche und
intensiver Überprüfung aller
eingegangenen Hinweise stellt die
Polizei die Suche nach Scarlett vorerst
ein sofort darauf gründen Scarletts
Angehörige die Facebookgruppe bitte
findet Scarlet und organisieren private
suchtrups um auf eigene Faust die
vermisste 26-Jährige zu finden über die
nächsten Tage Wochen und Monate laufen
sie immer wieder das fast 100
quadratkilomet große Gelände ab aber
Scarlett bleibt
verschwunden was eine unvorstellbar
schwere Zeit dass für Scarletts Eltern
für ihre Schwester oder auch ihren
Freund Joey in China sein muss Scarlett
gefallen hätte sie noch gerettet werden
können ist sie abgehauen oder hat er
jemand etwas angetan im Sommer 2021
engagiert der suchtrup ein Mantrailing
Einsatzteam also speziell ausgebildete
Spürhunde die bei der Suche nach
Vermissten helfen und obwohl Scarlet zu
diesem Zeitpunkt schon fast ein Jahr
verschwunden ist ist nimmt der Hund
tatsächlich ihre Witterung auf
kilometerweit zieht das Tier den
privaten suchtrup durch den
Schluchtensteig auf den Wegen auf denen
Scarlet Monat zuvor wahrscheinlich auch
gewandert ist und die Natur genoss doch
dann die
Wendung noch einmal Jörg völkerling wir
befinden uns auf einem Parkplatz entlang
der Landstraße 148 etwa 7 km außerhalb
von todmos hier gibt es keinerlei
Handyempfang links und rechts der Straße
steigen tief und dunkel die Wälder
hervor wer hier alleine wandert der ist
tatsächlich auf sich selbst gestellt und
dennoch nahm ein mentailerhund hier an
diesem Findling die letzte Spur von
Scarlett
auf wie kann das sein lief Scarlet den
Rest der sechsten Etappe nicht zu Ende
brach sie vorzeitig ab haben die
Einsatzkräfte vielleicht an einer
falschen Stelle nach ihr gesucht kann es
sein dass garlett gar nicht im
Schluchtensteig verschwunden ist die
letzte Frage stellte sich auch auch Jörg
völkerling gab dieser an Benjamin Ernst
den Kommandant der Feuerwehr todmos
weiter
also wir finden es eher unrealistisch
dass sie sich da noch befindet
geschweige denn dass man jetzt noch
irgendwie was finden könnte weil so wie
mir das abgesucht haben kann es
eigentlich nicht sein dass das jetzt
noch was
auftaucht bleibt eigentlich nur ein
freiwilliges oder unfreiwilliges
verschwinden abtauchen ja kann man so
sagen fakt ist auch eine Zeugin gab kurz
nach Scarletts verschwinden gegenüber
der Polizei an dass sie Scarlett auf
diesem Parkplatz gesehen hätte da zur
gleichen Zeit jedoch eine andere blonde
Wanderin in den Schluchtensteig
unterwegs war wurde damals dieser Ansatz
wieder
verworfen tatsächlich geht nach der
spürhundsuche eine Anzeige bei der
Polizei in paderbaun ein die zuständige
Staatsanwaltschaft im Schwarzwald leitet
wenig später ein sogenanntes
tötungsermittlungsverfahren ein wir
hören was damals Staatsanwalt Dr Michael
blotzig zu dieser
sagte also es ist tatsächlich Anfang
August dieses Jahres eine Anzeige
erstattet worden wegen eines
Gewaltverbrechens diese Anzeige ist muss
ich sagen relativ hersärmlich und
spekulativ nennt keine belastbaren
Beweismittel für einen solchen Vorwurf
wir haben um diese anzeage zu genüg
tatsächlich förmlich ein
Todesermittlungsverfahren eingeleitet
wir haben aber bis dahin das muss auch
ganz klar betont werden überhaupt gar
keine Hinweise auf ein
Gewaltverbrechen im Sommer
2022 ist scarlets verschwinden noch
einmal Thema in der Sendung Aktenzeichen
XY über 70 Hinweise gehen im Anschluss
bei den Ermittlern ein der Entscheidende
ist aber nicht dabei als im Oktober 202
eine Wanderin im Schluchtensteig Knochen
findet steigt noch mal die Hoffnung das
Verschwinden von Scarlet aufklären zu
können die Überprüfung ergeben aber dass
es sich bei den Knochen um tierische
handelt die Staatsanwaltschaft hat das
sogenannte Todesermittlungsverfahren im
Fall Scarlet inzwischen eingestellt
heißt die Ermittler gehen nicht von
einem Fremdverschulden aus Scarletts
verschwinden liegt damit wieder bei der
Polizei und wird von den Ermittlern wie
ein Vermissten Fall
behandelt es ist wirklich schwierig es
verschwinden ja oft Menschen auch immer
wieder Frauen muss man sagen und viele
dieser Fälle sind leider am Ende
Gewaltverbrechen wie es sich dann
herausstellt aber bei Skales
verschwinden da gibt es überhaupt keinen
richtigen Anhaltspunkt alles scheint
möglich mich übrigens Mirko erinnert da
doch einiges in diesem Gefühl dazu an
den Fall Inka köntkes in Hannover es
liegt hier z.B die Vermutung nah dass
sie abgestürzt ist aber was wenn eben
nicht was ist mit ihrer Spur die am
Parkplatz endet das alles eine quälende
ungewisheit das maryrium welches
scarlets Angehörige seit diesem
Herbsttag im Jahr 2020 erleben das ist
wirklich schwer vorstellbar jahrelang
hat Scarlett die ganze Welt bereist und
das furchtlos sie entdeckte fremde
Länder und Kulturen doch ausgerechnet im
Schwarzwald nur 500 km von ihrem Zuhause
entfernt verschwindet sie spurlos
am 10 September 2023 jte sich skarz
verschwinden zum dritten mal kurz vor
diesem traurigen Jahrestag
veröffentlicht ihr Vater einen
bewegenden Appell auf Facebook in vier
Tagen ist es jetzt der dritte Jahrestag
ihres Verschwindens oder genau gesagt
1095 Tage in Ungewissheit Angst Sorge
was mit Scarlet passiert
ist man gewöhnt sich nicht an diesen
Zustand und man will sich auch nicht
daran gewöhnen und nach wie vor wird
alles unternommen sie zu
finden und eine Spur zu finden was
geschehen ist an diesem 10 September dre
Wochen später folgt der nächste Post auf
der Facebookseite es ist ein Foto von
Scarlett sie steht mitten in einem Meer
aus gelben Blumen darüber steht
herzlichen Glückwunsch zum Geburtstag
Scarlet wo auch immer du bist wir denken
an Dich happy
Birthday Geburtstagsgrüße Trauernder
Eltern an Scarletts 30
Geburtstag das war unsere heutige Folge
von Tatort Deutschland falls ihr
Hinweise zu skaretz verschwinden habt
wendet euch bitte an die Polizei alle
Informationen dazu findet ihr wie immer
in den Show Notes wir haben mit Quellen
vom SÜDKURIER dem SWR Aktenzeichen XY
und unserer eigenen berichterstatt
insbesondere von Reporter jöerling
gearbeitet schön dass ihr auch dieses
Mal wieder dabei wart bei Anregung oder
Feedback schreibt uns gerne eine Mail an
podcast@bild.de oder schickt uns eine
Nachricht bei Instagram bis dahin alles
Gute und bis zum nächsten Mal euer Mirko
und euer
Stefan dir hat diese Folge von T
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle
auf dich wie das Verschwinden von
Rebecca Rusch der Prozess gegen OJ
Simpson oder die Entführung von ursela
Hermann wir hören uns bei Tat
Deutschland